today a radio broadcaster says he's
still traumatized
a van intercepted me and my daughter as
we were leaving the tunnel and five
people got out of another vehicle onto
the teeth
they grabbed my daughter from the
driver's seat I tried to run in vain
after 30 minutes they let her out and
said we have the wrong person
they were exceptionally Lucky in Ecuador
kidnapping extortion and murders have
become an epidemic
one presidential candidate and two
congressional candidates were murdered
this month underscoring why the number
one electoral issue is violence
I'm just outside of the Electoral
Authority headquarters here in Quito
ahead of Sunday's elections you can see
that security has been increased but
when you talk to ordinary ecuadorians
they tell you that they don't make them
feel safer that they're not part of the
solution but often part of the problem
yeah
in Ecuador's penitentiaries security
forces are in lead with criminal gangs
and Drug leaders corruption and
penetration of organized crime into
State institutions especially Security
Forces is undeniable
this man who didn't want to give his
name says everyone knows that even the
justice system is corrupted
every day more bodies appear some are
decapitated or dismembered or hanging
from a bridge what has happened to this
country Dear God
but violence isn't the only problem
seventy-year-old Gustavo Sambrano sells
dustpans in the city center but he has a
lot of competition
everywhere people are selling whatever
they can to survive
here no one will give you even a piece
of bread if you don't look for ways to
buy a piece of bread no one will give
you a crumb
mounted unemployment poverty and crime
are connected
seven out of ten people don't have
formal work so how can we expect that a
country living in acute poverty they
won't be violence that's impossible
there's little expectation that whoever
is elected will be able to solve the
crisis which is why more ecuadorians
than ever before are leaving their
country in search of work and safety
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Quito